well joining us now is the education
secretary Damon Hines thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning now I just mentioned in the
intro this week I went to Wotton mmm in
Norfolk and the message that I've got
there from people very strongly was they
want breaks it to happen even if it
means no deal they want to get on with
it
so can you reassure people in wotton and
elsewhere that we will be leaving the EU
on March the 29th yes we will I mean
there was a very clear very clear
instruction came from people in the
referendum and of course subsequently we
had the votes in Parliament's to trigger
article 50 we have the date of the 29th
of March set out it's up to everybody in
Parliament now to make sure we find the
common ground to make sure we can move
forward with a sensible balanced
negotiated eggs and that's what I'm
totally focused on because the reason
that we're asking a question of course
is the series of amendments we've got
coming up next week where MPs are
effectively saying if MPs can't reach an
agreement then rather than leaving
without a deal there should be an
extension to article 50 so if it does
come down to that which of those two
options which you prefer so prolonging
these things doesn't necessarily help
you you know saying we'd delay the
process doesn't actually find a way
through it just kicks the can a bit
further down the road what we in
Parliament need to do is do what we're
there for which is to debate to discuss
but then to come together and to work
out what is the way through and we
should be trying to absolutely avoid a
no deal that would be a bad outcome but
we absolutely can't have a second
referendum or undoing the brakes that
process we need to have a as I say you
know a sensible balanced negotiated exit
there is I'm sure there is common ground
to do that we have to find it and we
have to move forward with you say
there's common ground
yes reason they lost that vote by 230
not 20 here I get that no I'm not saying
it's a small task clearly you know we're
engaged in a huge debate on this massive
issue the biggest or a single political
issue which has been around since I've
been not under since I've been in
politics as I've been politically aware
and one which doesn't cut along party
lines and that makes it harder but but
it's a obviously incredibly important
that we do it and as I say I think the
common ground actually is there if you
look at what some of the different
proposals are the difference between
them isn't quite as great as sometimes
it appears not to we'll throw around the
the labels and the terminology so I
think we can come together so just be
clear then if it is I know that you want
to get the deal done of course you do of
course you want to find that common
ground but if you can't and it is a
choice then as the amendment by Evette
Cooper is trying to kind of pinpoint
between leaving on the 29th of March
with no deal or delaying which would you
prefer
that just doesn't solve anything it just
says yeah we'll put it off a bit further
now we've had we've had a long time to
debate this no I'd prefer us to get on
with it and get the negotiated deal and
there's no reason why we shouldn't be
able to do that and as I said there is
quite a lot of common ground and when
you think about what people's starting
positions aren't think about how they
might come somewhat closer together you
do end up with you know whichever
starting point you come from you're
doing it with something pretty close to
the negotiator deal the Prime Minister
house so I want us to focus all our
energies on moving forward towards her
and it sounds as if the government may
be moving towards trying to get some
kind of compromise on the backstop
agreement which would of course bring
some conservative MPs 10 to the DEP back
on side and one of the amendments is
asking for that backstop to be time
limited is that something that the
government would support so the the
backstop is is an integral part of the
withdraw all agree I know you're going
to have the Irish Minister on there to
be you have an opportunity to talk about
these things directly it is you know
that the backstop exists as a cast-iron
guarantee to not return to a hard border
between Northern Ireland and the
Republic and as I say it's been an
integral part of the withdrawal
agreement there are legitimate concerns
some of my colleagues and the Democratic
Unionist Party on aspect the backstop
and of course they do it would be
helpful and and it's already been
helpful actually to have some further
reassurances on that coming back from
the European Union but it's also worth
saying that there's no particular reason
to believe the backstop is going to come
into place anyway there's only an
insurance policies only yes and my
question was about will the government
support the backstopping time-limited
it's not it's not really a question
where the
government will support it or not this
isn't something which is entirely in the
gift of one side or other in the
negotiation it's an integral part of
their withdrawal agreement and any
negotiated exit' involves a withdrawal
agreement and any withdrawal agreement
would involve a backstop absolutely I
would support their being you know
additional reassurances if some were
possible on the way the backstop would
operate but we shouldn't and we
shouldn't over focus just on that aspect
because there are multiple reasons to
believe the backstop would never come
into place and even if it did actually
there's some advantages to the backstop
as well as as well as drawbacks what we
should be focusing on is the overall
package well the overall future
arrangement talking about the overall
package because made it pretty clear
this week that if the backstop is to
reweave visitors than the price of that
would be a permanent customs union can
you see the government pivoting in that
direction
well my understanding is that that is
not that is not a correct depiction of
any of any particular conversation that
that happens when we talk about the the
customs union versus the Prime
Minister's negotiated deal so the
customs union has put forward by the
labor front bench me my question to them
is what is it about the customs union
which is so important to you which is
not in the Prime Minister's negotiated
agreement and I have yet to hear a good
answer to that because they because then
why don't you offer the customs union
that could have a majority well it's not
in our gift to go offering things so way
back at the start of these negotiation
with you it's a negotiation with 27
other nations and rather started this
process they only said there's two
options on the table there's the Norway
style option or the Canada style option
and actually what's happened is the
British government the Prime Minister
and some of our best diplomats have
managed to negotiate something which is
better than either of those something
which is bespoke to the UK it gets the
best of the customs union with being
able to have good trade across borders
gets us out of the agriculture policy in
the Fisheries Policy but also means we
can strike our trade deals around the
world that leverages our strength in
services it ends free movement it
is a good deal it's a good balanced deal
it's not one of these off-the-shelf
options
it is something bespoke and tailored for
Britain and better than those options if
the government were to move towards No
Deal could you support that and remain
in government
I don't envisage No Deal becoming
government policy because we are all
totally focused on making sure we get
out of the European Union we do what we
were told to do by the British people
but we do in a way which is good for
their which is good for their jobs I am
focused on the here and now I'm focused
on getting a good negotiated exit done
and as I say I don't envisage a scenario
in which that question comes out I don't
envisage a scenario in which No Deal
becomes government policy but it is
important that it is it remains as a as
a possibility because you know on the
other hand there's still the possibility
some people trying to thwart brings it
all together
I want from both of those sides people
to be moving a little bit towards each
other so we come to be good negotiated
exit deal and some of your colleagues
have made it pretty clear though that
they are willing to step down if No Deal
does become effectively government
policy well you'd have to I mean that's
something only individuals obviously can
answer for as I say I don't envisage
that becoming government policy we want
to avoid a No Deal No Deal would not be
a good outcome but it doesn't have to be
the outcome of but when Wendy would say
take therefore take no deal off the
table you can't just take a negative
away you have to replace it with
something and the way to not have no
deal I know this sounds a bit over
simplistic sometimes and a bit of a play
on words but the way to not have a no
deal is to have a deal and that is what
all of us in Parliament have to focus on
this week now I do want to ask you a bit
about your brief while you're here and
this week some some day I hope we had
the day when we can spend the whole
interview about education that would be
very refreshing and you're launching
your drive to try and recruit teachers
because it's it's effectively it could
blow up into a recruitment crisis here
couldn't it and unless you get the best
people in those schools one of the
things that we're offering is to try and
tell parents very nicely to stop
emailing their teachers so much I mean
come on it's going to take a bit more
than that isn't it of course it takes a
lot and not more than that I mean to
start the beginning of what you said yes
outstanding people working in our
schools is fundamental to education and
we do have outstanding people working
our schools but we need to keep making
sure there's more and more of them we've
got about 450,000 teachers in this
country and that's about 10,000 up on
2010 but we've got we've had a growing
pupil population and we need to make
sure that the profession remains a
compelling attractive prospect and there
are some things which are working
against that like workload and that's
why I'm so focused on trying to bear
down on workload part of work they're
not the only part is email and I think
for all of us in all of our different
jobs there's been a bit of an explosion
in correspondence and communication
through email for teachers I think it
can happen even more so I'm not saying -
pear is never email the school or never
email pair because the teach because
that can be really important it's more a
question of you think about everything
else the teachers got on in terms of
lesson planning and preparation and
marking and so on and and and just a bit
of self-restraint when it comes to email
I mean I'm not an expert here but I
can't help but thinking if you want to
recruit more teachers and better
teachers you've got to pay them more and
actually if half years of pay restraint
for teachers and analysis by labor in
2417 found teachers a 5,000 a year worse
off compared to 2010 I mean that's the
figures are supported by the nu T where
all those years of squeezing teachers
pay a mistake pay clearly is an
important part of the attractiveness of
the profession as it is to other of
course to other walks of life and it is
possible you know through career
progression in teaching to build a build
a good career of course the teachers
pension is a very strong pensioners a
good part of that of that proposition of
that proposition as well but you know
it's also true that after the crash of
2008 there was I mean there was pay
restraint manifested in different ways
actually right across society not just
in the public sector and the private
sector as well but but we've just I mean
we've just had a larger pay increase for
for teachers ranging between one and a
half percent and three and a half
percent on the difference on the
different pay scales and I do of course
I totally accept that pay remains an
important part but workload is also very
important that's why I'm working to bear
down on that
also make sure that flexibility is
available in work so that when yet
perhaps for family reasons or other
reasons people wanna be able to work
part-time or in a job share to make sure
that those options are available okay
we're out of time thank you very much
thank you Sophie